just a week's officer announcing his
triumphant return as Superman Henry
Cavill had to take it all back here's
how some DC die-hards are fighting the
Studio's decision
when the news first dropped at director
James Gunn and producer Peter saffron
would take charge of the DC film
universe and I knew Warner Brothers
Discovery CEO David zazlov it was
implied that the duo would attempt to
steer the franchise in something of a
new Direction in one surprising move
under their stewardship longtime DC
Superman actor Henry Cavill revealed
that he's Superman no longer though a
new Superman movie is planned and Gunn
intends to maintain a working
relationship with caval moving forward
gun posted on Twitter in the initial
stages our story will be focusing on an
earlier part of Superman's life so the
character will not be played by Henry
Cavill but we just had a great meeting
with Henry and we're big fans and we
talked about a number of exciting
possibilities to work together in the
future on Instagram cavalshed I have
just had a meeting with James Gunn and
Peter Safran and it's sad news everyone
I will after all not be returning a
Superman after being told by the studio
to announce my return back in October
prior to to their higher this news isn't
the easiest but that's life now that
kavel is a free agent fans of other
major movie franchises have begun to
propose ideas for his next big role for
instance someone's travel to join the
MCU given his superhero experience and
presumably his superhero movie ready
physique meanwhile other sing caval is a
good fit for James Bond especially with
the roll's current vacancy in mind of
course caval May instead separate
himself from franchise films entirely
with his Superman exit following his
departure from Netflix's The Witcher
enjoy your last walk across the matter
and through the Mist whatever his future
may be plenty of fans are unsurprisingly
unhappy about cavil's departure in fact
some are going so far as to call for
guns head over the decision soon after
Henry cavill's departure from the DC
film Universe broke users on Twitter
began to share their disappointment with
James Gunn
civically over the news under the
hashtag fire James Gunn one user shared
a screenshot of cavil's Instagram posts
confirming his departure with the
caption fire James Gunn pass it on
meanwhile in another post utilizing the
hashtag another user argued that this
news is particularly disappointing given
both Carvel's apparent interest in
remaining Superman and the fact that
Black Adam seem to tease a future caval
Superman storyline that bonnets released
about a month and a half prior Black
Adam
you talk the hashtag has generated
plenty of discussion Beyond just these
posts too to the extent that the
conversation has reached at least one
additional platform eventually
discussion of James Gunn's firing over
his decision to proceed without Henry
Cavill reached enough of a critical mass
that someone started a change.org
petition for the course this petition
names Warner Brothers Discovery CEO
David zazlov as its intended audience
urging him to rehire Cavill and fire gun
arguing that Cavill is a Bonafide movie
star and capable of generating more
Revenue than gun can as one of DC's
leads as of the making of this video the
petition has garnered 500 signatures and
climbing while such a petition isn't
likely to influence zar's love or effect
cavill's career the amounts of
signatures It ultimately receives can
nevertheless serve as a measure of the
degree to which those upset about
cavil's firing think that gun's job
should be impacted by this decision of
course these sentiments aren't
reflective of DC film fans as a whole
butts are never Less in steady
circulation following the caval news gun
and Peter Safran are still at the start
of their DC Journey so once the DC film
Universe has time to develop under their
guidance such sentiments could very well
change